And we must take back the professional
nearing. From science because you think.
Medical science is not
a healing profession.
It's a profession which manages the
symptoms in the body and that's not healing
and in fact they don't believe in healing
because they believe in the context of
wounds healing for example but
that there is a healing intelligence
within the body which can be assisted
by natural medicines for totally
outside of the their science
and their realm of
experience but they feel
that because of the
orthodoxy of their training
that they have the right to pass
judgment on the natural therapies.
It's almost like they feel they have a god
given right it's like being a monarch
you know you have a god given right
to rule because of your birth
and your place in society and they
have no qualms about accepting
that role and. I don't think.
Well i don't know that from
my perspective they feel
that they're doing the right thing
by society. They certainly.
I suppose they have to justify the.
Sixty thousand dollars or
whatever really of the year
but they earn by continuing to.
Being a little dura crass and create
regulations and legislation etc..
I mean what would we do without them.
Why do i think that. Well.
What people forget is that human
beings are part of nature
that we have evolved on this
planet along with all the plants
and all the animals and the atmosphere
and the water the mineral together.
And consequently we share
life. Like a system.
And for something like four
million years human beings
lived on this planet and
when irish fire in accordance with
the natural cycles of the seasons
and the things that grew so it has
developed us. We haven't developed it.
And now we're totally cut off from that
and we don't live within a natural cycle
we for example eat things all year round.
That should only be eaten for a short
time of the year like tomatoes very
irritating to the system and a lot
of people are allergic to them
and yet we expect them to have them
on our table in the dead of winter.
And often we're totally out of touch
with our bodies we get messages
that we completely misinterpreted or
you know we don't know what to do
when we get them don't know
how to heal ourselves.
So we've broken away from nature and the
system which grew us and nourished us
and is there to keep to bring
us back to a healthy state.
We've lost lost it and.
I mean even in the early parts of this
century there was a lot of knowledge of folk
medicine.
People couldn't afford to go to doctors a
lot of people knew how to heal themselves
with foods and who was in
wrist and things like that
that we have lost and that to me a big
part of natural therapies is the.
Education the re-education of people in
the traditional grass roots folk medicine
which is very effective and useful
and people need it.
Nowadays people get ill and they want to
go somewhere in take a pill get a pill
that will enable them to stay at work for
example they don't want to take five days
off and wrist and maybe faster a couple
of days and just have vegetables
and fruit and and.
Retreating to themselves and think about
the stresses in their life direction
and why they're getting
ill and things like that.
They just want to ignore that totally
and take a pill and have it all go away
and the medical profession has
encouraged them mightily in
that response because that's
where the health dollar is.
That's what it's all about to them.
They want that responsibility.
They want people to come to them
for every little complaint.
Although now the health system is getting
overwhelmed with people who have been
conditioned to do exactly that.
And now just the other
day i heard on the radio
that they're wanting to encourage people
to think before they go to the doctor
about whether their complaint
is really a trivial one
and they might be able to take care of it
themselves because the systems getting
overwhelmed.
The spiritual side of healing well.
In a sense there is no spiritual side of
healing because if you are a holistic
practitioner there is no division
mind body and spirit are all one
and into woven through
every cell of our being so
that is a spiritual component
to your liver. And.
There is a large balcony.
Don't your thoughts.
So that people don't for example imagine
that you can treat depression through
physical natural medicine but you can.
Just the same as if you're treating physical
complaint you often have to go into
the emotional aspects of them.
So there really isn't any division and
but we really stuck with the mind body
split which again is sort of developed in
the last 300 years through cartesian
philosophy through being really locked into
the physical that's the only
area we explored for 300 years
and we only just this century starting
to explore the mind with our infant
professions of psychiatry and psychology.
And even people who are involved in natural
medicine don't really realize a lot of
the time. I get clients
that come to me who just want a pill to
fix their problems and it can go away
and they can go back
to work and they think
that they're practicing alternative medicine
by doing that but they don't realize.
Really what holistic medicine.
Means on a personal level.
But. Getting back to spiritual healing.
This it needs such a thing as spiritual
healing you know where people achieve
healing through laying on of hands
through prayer. Through meditation.
And really the type of healing has to
suit the person you can't force a person
to take up a particular approach to healing
people have to do what they feel is
right for them and.
And of course they do.
So that's why you know and the wonderful
thing really about australia is that.
We have free. Much freedom of choice.
With what type of medicine we.
Entail providing we can afford it.
There's tremendous sort of financial
discrimination against natural therapies
because people have to pay for
them out of their pocket.
But the fact is that they do. I
mean they support. A growing.
Natural therapies industry
out of their own pockets
and it's now estimated to be worth.
I don't know half a billion
dollars a year to australia.
That was a figure that the australian
natural therapies association came up with
and that includes not only consultations
but all the manufacturing side of it.
For example health food stores.
A huge
and growing industry which is beginning
to have an impact on our economy.
So i think that we must retain
that choice we have to have all types
of healing available to people.
From spiritual healing to natural meds
into orthodox scientific medicine
and there's a place for all of them.
And certainly because of my nursing
background i'm pretty familiar with what
orthodox medicine can achieve and i
would never say we must not have it
that it's place.
Really it's dramatic medicine it's acute
medicine it's risk you emergency.
It deals with things when
they've gotten so out of hand
that the person is not capable or
anyone else capable of healing.
And if it stuck to that
role that would be great
but it's tries to step
into situations and.
There are so many you know chronic
and subacute complaints which are
amenable to healing but that people
when they go to orthodox medicine and.
Don't get healing they get management
which involves taking drugs.
Maybe for the rest of your life.
And while they may sustain.
All life for some time.
Whether they actually take years off your
life in the long term is open to question
what the quality of your life
is. Is another matter and.
It also takes a takes.
The prospect of healing.
Away takes responsibility for the
individual for their health away.
But the face of all kinds of medicine
is changing dramatically in australia
and its very exciting.
With mental illness.
Probably the most interesting development
in that area would be authored sorry.
Also molecular medicine which is
a branch of orthodox medicine
but they only use.
What i described as natural medicines
like gardens and minerals for example.
And they rely they do rely on
science through there and.
The signings research.
Say
that most of the things they practice been
backed up by research so that's another
interesting development within
the ranks of orthodox medicine.
And this far as natural
therapies are concerned
and their their role in the
treatment of mental illness.
I don't think a lot of natural therapies
treat. Serious mental illnesses.
You know the sort of groups that
have psychotic manifestations.
But certainly amongst the
the neurotic therapies.
Sorry disorders is probably a fee.
Representation of natural therapies and
by that i will. Includes things like.
Psychology which is a natural
therapy. Rebirthing and.
Various gushed out there pieces
about a man and mineral syrupy.
A lot of people go to natural
therapist for stress.
Sleeplessness anxieties things like that.
So then we kind of mundane
and day to day emotional disorders are
certainly approached by natural syrup is
but the more serious ones on the whole no.
Yes touch is really important
in the healing arts
and a lot of people go to natural therapists
who do body work on a regular basis
because.
Often it's the only sort
of touching that they get
and this this particular team has really
been taken up with in the nursing
profession.
For example say with older people in
nursing homes and the recognition
that they are very deprived
of physical contact so
that their you know increasingly within
nursing homes for example there are
programs to incorporate massage.
Reflexology. Aroma syrupy
things like that that include.
That are based on touch.
I guess a lot of that just goes
back to the sort of society
that we live in where we
have a lot of conflict
and confusion around the
body touch sexual issues so
that the natural therapy certainly
plays an important role
in. Providing that.
And that's been a difficult thing for so
the massaged therapists for example who
often get confused with. People
who provide sexual services.
For some people in the you know
from the public perception.
Massages a sexual event.
And yet that's not what most body workers
see themselves as providing they.
I guess the way i would look at it is
that there's a big difference between.
Sensuality and touch
and sexuality then there are
different sort of things going on.
And and touch in itself can.
Through it. Sensuality through.
And then if it transference of
energy. Through its counterfeiting.
Can be extremely healing
and that's a very different thing
from the sort of sexual release
that one gets from certain other types of.
People who provide physical services
and we don't differentiate between those
words of things very easily we haven't
talked about it within our culture and
massaged wasn't a part of our culture.
Prior to a few decades ago
and i think it's sort of part of our
the freeing up of the whole body thing
basically in our society which
i think is very important
and it's going through all
kinds of phases in its
and manifestations some
of them quite horrible.
But it's you know i think they
said it's really necessary
that we free up a lot of
our attitudes to the body.
They've been making us ill
on all sorts of levels.
Well sexuality is something we
can't separate out you know.
We have i mean we've been repressed
that it's been tabu for a long time
and now it's emerging as a very sensual
part of our being in something
that we need to explore and heal.
And you know. As i said it's just.
I think it's at the necessary part of the
whole kind of taking responsibility for
one's healing thing
and for example sexual issues are
responsible for a lot of marriage breaks
that break up.
Because people go into sexual
relationships with so little knowledge.
Especially when you're young.
So little experience and they
can be devastating if people
and we don't do enough teaching of those
sorts of things in you know for young
people and all of
that those issues are really fraught
because they become bound up with moral.
Interpretations of reality
and we don't have a simple
straightforward comfort of all
experience with our
bodies a lot of the time.
In terms of.
In terms of workshops just
relating to sexuality.
There's some of
that sort of healing work going on
in this area there in men's groups
and workshops happening. Within
the context of rebirthing.
For example as a therapy sexual issues
often come up for people with all of those
kind of psychological therapies they get
that they're part of the issues they're
really fundamental to a lot of people's
problems and so they come up
and yes they're workshops you see
advertised around from challenge a time on
sexuality and relationships.
It's not my particular area so i
don't know a lot about how those
workshops around
but see if they do occur whether it's more
in this area than in the big cities i
don't know maybe not.
Yes. I think it.
I think you know military action and.
Well certainly kind of dropping out
of society is very confronting and.
There is a lot of inner growth and
personal exploration goes on up here.
I mean amongst the people
that i know there.
It's just sort of second nature to
be talking about our inner lives
and the challenges that
confront us on that level and.
I don't know how much
that goes on in wider society i know it's
certainly increasing i mean you can pick
up all sorts of magazines and things
like that and find articles that reflect
that interest. The
personal growth movement.
And that's a very important component
for example of marriage guidance.
Associations.
And certainly it's a really
important aspect of leisure.
I think that when people it's
like meddlers hierarchy even.
He's once people's basic needs are
met for food shelter security on a
more physical level then we become free
to explore other issues you can't explore
your personal growth.
Really when years starving somali
it's not an issue but up here.
Where people have more time
and certainly i think now with
so many people unemployed.
And so many people. Facing
issues such as stress.
There was a story on the radio the other
day about how many more meaning going
along to counsellors about stresses in their
lives particularly with the recession
and loss of income and things like that.
And so certainly people are turning inward
and looking at themselves in the
way they react to life situations
and not simply reacting and acting out
and being out of touch with what they're
doing they're actually thinking about the
way they react to things
and questioning themselves about
well can i react differently.
I cannot look at this situation
in a more positive light.
You know do i have to feel
overwhelmed out of it.
What can i do to turn this
into a creative situation that
that kind of thinking does
happen a lot out here. And.
There's a lot of innovative small
businesses for example in this area.
And that's being encouraged you know.
With government money desperate time.
Yes so i think
that the whole pretty personal growth
in the movement is to the forefront
here but certainly also growing
in wider society. Thank you.
Yes.
It.
Was.
Well around nimbin this been quite a
strong tradition over the last 20 years of
natural birth and home birth and
that was initiated by mothers themselves
who could not get anybody to attend their
birth at home. And so a
group of women who believe
that they should have the right
to a natural birth known
and not have unnecessary intervention
saw that the only way they could do
that was to train themselves
and provide themselves with
that service which they did and
most of those lay midwives.
Competent and well-trained and responsible
and have very good statistics in their
care of mothers able to pick up
when there's a problem and transfer
they have a higher transfer rate.
Then qualified midwives.
In other words they tend
to transfer sooner.
But yes they've just been deemed
to be illegal in new south wales.
And that's very threatening for birth
and beyond in nimbin because they have
largely been an organisation which has
depended upon a midwives
and birth assistants to
provide care and support.
And without them to think beyond
itself may be in jeopardy.
And it is in australia.
One of the few examples of successful
community development in health as an asset
as a as an organisation.
It is the an ideal in terms of what the
world health organization wishes to promote
right around the world.
With as what they call primary health care
and putting health care into the
hands of the community the earth
and beyond have been doing that 14 years
and now that's under threat because of the
nurses registration board in new south
wales. Who basically had from out
of this is an issue of safety.
And yet that can't be proven
and the opposite has been shown.
There has been the odd lay midwives
who've done way out things
and have jeopardized the issue of lay
midwifery for other more numerous
and more responsible people but
the nurses. Registration board.
I'm not sure if i've got the right
name as it association there but.
Anyway the professional associations of
nurses have totally overlooked for example
the right of women to choose a health
care practitioner who is not an official
health care practitioners they've
totally overlooked the world health
organization's.
Philosophy with regard to traditional
medicine and lay midwifery.
If these women who are practicing
lay midwifery existed in africa
or india they would be lauded for their
activities they would be assisted with
government grants.
They would be assisted with educational
programs that here they're simply.
Denigrated ostracized made a legal
threatened with jail and fines.
And.
Why.
Right.
As well as the lame it was along
with most i would say home birth midwives
qualified ones very much holistic
practitioners and that really.
Influences dramatically the
way they approach birth.
As a life event a powerful
impact for the family involved.
And interestingly enough if you
look at any nursing course.
In fact the nurses registration board itself
defines nursing as an art as well as a
science.
They promote holistic nursing they promote
the actual use of intuition of ones.
You know knowing
that develops over time with
exposure to people in the healing
and health professions.
But in the hospital with this there isn't
room very much for this to happen.
The people who are actually doing it.
Tend to be those holistic nursing practitioners
who operate outside the system such
as nurses who move into natural
medicine nurses who become.
Midwives who become home
with practitioners.
And women often mothers who take up.
Lay midwifery who being birth assistance.
They're the ones who are truly
providing holistic nursing care.
It's an interesting irony.
Well. The way that midwives use in
she was in for example in birth.
Probably most often comes
that we get situations of delay
where mothers seem to get stuck.
No no further dilation of the cervix.
An hour or two more and where the whole
process seems to be bogged down.
Now if you were in hospital what would
happen would be they'd put up a drip
and put in oxytocin to
stimulate the uterus
and speed the whole process apple
they'd rupture your membranes.
And they'd probably the main approaches.
So it's kept it a very
physical process but.
Holistic midwives would
look at that situation
and wonder was there something
blocking the person.
The mother involved and they
would wait. They would talk.
They would use all kinds
of comforting measures.
Everything from say hot towels a
physical pain to touch massage.
And providing a really safe
and loving environment for the
mother to get into her stuff
and explore on an emotional
level. What's going on.
Along with standard observation of mother
in baby you know fetal heart rate all of
those sorts of things to make
sure that things were going well
and we were remaining
within normal limits.
And you get breakthroughs in those
situations for example i was at a birth.
Some years ago where.
The woman involved was running a
business and she was the mainstay of
that business. And her partner.
Knew a bit about it but she was
really deep down concerned
that at the conflict between her having
to stop her involvement in the business
and just be a mother and whether
that was going to be okay and.
So she got to transition
and she just balked
and she was very restless
an educated and anxious
and crawling around on the bed for
an hour or something. This went on.
And when we just lit it then we took her
and we cuddled there and we you know.
Tried to help her get down into it and
finally she just burst out with it with.
The words. Is it okay for
me to be the mother.
And we all said yes it's a ok.
And with that she just went
straight into second stage invested
that well she just let go then and she
started to birth a baby and she set up.
In a sort of meditation
position and she said.
After you know a few more
minutes of just calm
and relaxing she said i feel all full
of light and then baby came out.
And those would have situations just don't
happen very really you know hospital
and. That's why women choose home birth.
That's why a lot of midwives go into a
home birth because they can be real
authentic midwives.
They can be creative spiritually
and emotionally as well as competent
responsible practitioners taking care of the
physical
water birth and.